les prises d'otages les attentats
perpétrés en europe afin d'attirer
l'attention sur la situation au
moyen-orient le terrorisme c'est je
crois monsieur le ministre la première
préoccupation d'amis de l'intérieur
monsieur pasqua oui c'est la
préoccupation du gouvernement dans son
ensemble et plus particulièrement la
préoccupation du miz l'intérieur et de
bons collègues robert pandraud ministre
qui vaut près de moi et plus
particulièrement en charge de la série
l'impression que c'est un état de guerre
je crois que le terrorisme était un
fléau mondial
je crois que tous les pays sont menacés
mais que malheureusement la france
figure désormais parmi les cibles
favorites
alors il faut se donner les moyens de
lutter contre ce fléau qui a des moyens
juridiques
il ya des moyens pratiques le premier de
ses moyens c'est naturellement la
coordination et la concertation avec
tous les autres pays qui sont frappés
par semaine sur cette criante comme arme
dans cette guerre comme qu'est ce qui
vous manque comme arme dans cette guerre
je crois tout d'abord qu'il a manqué aux
autorités françaises la prise de
conscience en temps utile de ce que
représentait réellement comme danger
pour notre pays ce qui s'était mise en
hôtes venant du pont parle d'ailleurs
que le fait je ne polémiquerai pas
beaucoup non content de le constater je
l'avais pour preuve que le fait que
pousser par une sorte d' angélisme nos
prédécesseurs ont cru qu à partir du
moment où il militait s'est étendu les
cales
leurs sentiments et leurs convictions
pour une société plus juste
ceux qui luttaient par des moyens
violents contre le système abandonnerait
ce genre de lutte
c'était une vue de l'esprit et je ne
veux pour preuve que le fait à peine
libéré les responsables actions directes
ont repris les actions violentes
or il est clair que dans un pays
démocratique comme la france et dans
tous les pays démocratiques
le terrorisme doit être mis hors la loi
il n'y a aucune raison aucun prétexte
aucune excuse à utiliser la violence
pour se faire entendre
tous les moyens existent la liberté de
la presse de la liberté d'association la
liberté de réunion la liberté
d'expression par conséquent on n'a pas à
recourir à la violence et surtout
lorsqu'il s'agit de prendre qu'aux
motards
on le voit en syrie on l'a vu aussi dans
notre pays et de faire porter ses coûts
sur des innocents cela le gouvernement
actuel ne le tolère aura pas
l'insécurité doit changer de camp les
rentrer les terroristes et nous a bien
la guerre est engagée
justement que c'est mieux si ce n'est
pas un problème est ce que est ce qu'il
n'y ait pas un piège s quand par exemple
en prenant des mesures exceptionnelles
des mettre en place des dispositifs un
peu spectaculaire on ne risque pas de
donner au terrorisme qui parle encore
très important france plus d'importance
qu'il n'en a mais nous ne prenons pas de
mesures particulièrement spectaculaire
nous allons prendre les mesures que tous
les autres pays démocratiques ont pris
avant nous
nous allons d'abord centraliser les
renseignements nous allons contrôler
davantage nos frontières nous allons
établir un système informatisé de
contrôle des visas
nous allons délivrer des cartes
d'identité est falsifiable et nous
allons procéder aux vérifications et aux
contrôles qui sont indispensables
on a souvent voulu opposer la sécurité
des citoyens et les droits de l'homme
moi je crois que les deux sont
indissociables je voudrais d'ailleurs
que l'on considère à davantage le
ministère de l'intérieur
comme le ministère de la paix qu'autre
chose
je connais je ne connais rien de plus
beau comme nom que celui que l'on donne
aux
aux agents de la force publique qui sont
au bas de l'échelle ce que l'on voit
dans la rue ils s'appellent comme un
gardien de la paix il milite ils
risquent leur vie pour que tout le monde
vive en paix le premier des droits de
l'homme
c'est le droit à la sécurité à la
tranquillité et à la paix ça veut dire
pas de mesure d'exception par tribunaux
d'exception pas de lois d'exception dans
ça veut dire utiliser tous les moyens
que donne la loi pour poursuivre ceux
qui se sont mis hors la loi on n'a pas
besoin d'un arsenal supplémentaires on a
besoin de lois supplémentaires nous
allons les proposer au parlement
on a certainement besoin de coordonner à
la fois les recherches
c'est ce à quoi nous nous employons est
aussi l'instruction et c'est la raison
pour laquelle le premier ministre dans
sa déclaration notamment proposé la
création du charbon spécialisés à la
cour d'appel de paris parce que
lorsqu'on instruit une affaire ne sera
pas la côte sud est un nom mais ce sera
une chambre spécialisée avec des gens
qui seront habilités à suivre la
totalité d'une affaire et non pas avoir
des procédures morcelé et par pie ix et
en différents points du territoire
l'insécurité leucémie c'est aussi la
délinquance la bri et lagrave et
qu'est-ce qu'il faut changer dans le
dispositif dont vous héritez votre avis
écoutez je crois qu'il faut d'abord que
les que chacun
remplisse son rôle le rôle de la police
c'est d'une part d'assurer la prévention
est aussi la répression
c'est malheureusement indispensable on
n'est pas sûrs du monde déjà enfreignent
la loi
il faut bien utiliser des moyens pour
les contraindre à entrer dans le droit
chemin
on n'a pas respecté la loi on semblait
cependant nous interrompt entend plus
parler de répression que de prévention
et puis oui on en entend surtout parler
parce qu'ils commentent mais il est bien
évident que nous ne disposions pas la
prévention de la répression
alors il ya aussi cette cette phrase qui
est intéressant c'est de monsieur le
premier ministre
parlons de couvrir la police ça veut
dire quoi se dire que lorsqu'il ya des
bavures on ferma les yeux mais ça veut
dire 7 et mal interprétés écoutez vous
avez vous avez des citoyens qui ont
accepté qu'ils ont choisie parce que
finalement la police est une sorte de
cassure on n'entre pas dans la police
comme l'antre ptt tout de même ce métier
un peu plus difficile avec davantage de
risques on a choisi de se consacrer à la
protection de ses concitoyens par là
même on accepte parce qu'il faut le il
faut y penser
chaque année des dizaines de policiers
de gendarmes paient de leur vie
le
le risque le risque qu'ils ont assumée
il assume jusqu'au bout l'ip et de leur
vie la défense de leurs concitoyens à
laquelle ils se sont fous et alors pour
remplir convenablement leur mission les
membres des forces de l'ordre ont besoin
de quoi ils ont d'abord besoin que la
population centre car réalité c'est pour
assurer la paix et la tranquillité
publique qu'il prenne ses risques et ils
ont donc besoin d'être compris et
soutenu par la population
ça n'a pas toujours été le cas et ça ne
l'est pas encore tout à fait ça fait
partie de nos préoccupations et nous
allons nous y atteler et d'ardam tyson
naturellement besoin de se sentir à la
fois soutenue et compris aidés par leurs
supérieurs
comment voulez vous que des gens aillent
jusqu'au bout de leurs responsabilités
s'ils pensent qu'au dessus d'eux il ya
surtout des gens qui ne prendront pas
les leurs de responsabilités chacun doit
prendre les siennes ces minutes le
gouvernement semble lier le problème de
l'insécurité celui des étrangers
est-ce qu'il n'est pas un risque d et
anglaise sont globalement on a montré
d'une opa canon on ne doit pas lier les
deux problèmes mais je crois que les
étrangers voulaient parler des immigrés
crois que les immigrés ont besoin plus
que les autres encore d'un pouvoir qui
prennent en main les problèmes de
sécurité
parce qu'il y a une petite partie des
immigrés qui par leur comportement et
par la façon dont ils enfreignent la loi
et par les actes de délinquance au kerry
se livrent font rejaillir sur l'ensemble
de la population immigrée qui ne le
méritent pas une sorte de phénomène de
rejet ou de condamnation ça nous ne
l'acceptons pas alors il faut que les
choses soient claires ce trias moi je
suis gaulliste
qu'est ce que ça veut dire
le savez bien ce que ça veut dire ça
veut dire que je suis un de ceux qui
sont engagés pendant la guerre derrière
le général de gaulle qui ont combattu le
racisme le nazisme et c'est donc tout ce
qui peut de près ou de loin de
s'apparenter au racisme ou le
combattrons et de nous ne laisserons pas
se développer au délit de faciès dans
les rues pas du tout et la manière la
meilleure manière de l'empêcher c'est
que l'on dise aussi ceux ci lorsqu'un
des links are est un délinquant
ce n'est pas parce qu'il sera une
immigrée qu'il sera arrêté
mais s'il est immigré ça ne le protégera
pas d'être arrêté
monsieur pasqua une dernière question à
contenir une carte électorale on vous a
représenté avec des grands ciseaux et on
a parlé de découpage de charcutage
est-ce que la garantie de la commission
de magistrats est bien réel est ce que
nous serons ce que ces magistrats vous
recommanderont vous feront comme conseil
écoutez j'ai reçu des instructions du
premier ministre du gouvernement pour
préparer la loi les grandes et j'ai
essayé de gégé donc présenté au nom du
gouvernement un projet de loi qui donne
le maximum de garanties pour montrer que
nous ne voulons pas faire ce que nous
avons reproché à nos prédécesseurs
je rappelle que ceux qui me reprochent à
l'heure actuelle qui veut suspectent de
vouloir charcuter sommes des
spécialistes
parce que pour arriver à faire une loi
qu une spécialité dans un anonymat ne
l'était quand même jamais arrivé au
niveau elle est arrivée pour arriver à
faire en sorte qu'à marseille à la suite
de découpage celui qui a le plus de voix
n'est pas mr absolue qu'un le moins été
lui faut quand même le faire vous
l'admettrez avec moi alors nous nous
avons pris un certain nombre de
précautions
nous avons dit nous maintenant le même
nombre de députés au plan national cinq
cent soixante dix ans et nous maintenant
le même nombre de députés par
département
nous rétablissons la loi électorale
telle qu'elle existait auparavant
nous demandons simplement aux à
l'assemblée nationale parce qu'on ne
peut pas faire autrement nous nous
donner le pouvoir de pratiquer par
ordonnance pour redécouper les
circonscriptions alors je reconnais que
nous sommes dans une situation plus
favorable pour redécouper que ce que
nous l'aurions été s'il avait fait
redécouper les circonscriptions il y à
un arbre si le gouvernement de l'époque
au lieu de choisir la proportionnelle
avait choisi de redécouper suite était
plus difficile pour lui
pourquoi parce qu'il partait de
circonscription qui existait aujourd'hui
la table est rase mais nous avons pris
d'autres précautions et nous avons dit
notamment
nous nous posons un certain nombre de
conditions et de l'est de règles nous
avons dit le conseil constitutionnel a
considéré qu'il ne fallait pas qu'ils
aient les cadres supérieurs 1,8 pour
cent c'est à dire presque deux fois
entre la plus petite région la plus
petite circonscription la plus grande
nous ne disons 15 % seulement
et dans le même temps nous allons créer
une commission alors aujourd'hui un
grand débat on me dit est ce que les
travaux de cette commission ont rendu
public et moi c'est ce que j'ai proposé
donc vous souhaiter que le gouvernement
vous le dirai le gouvernement a proposé
que les avis de cette commission soit
rendue publique
nous ne l'avons pas retenue dans le
projet de loi parce que le conseil
d'état a considéré la publicité qui
serait donnée à ces travaux mais traite
en quelque sorte serait en quelque sorte
préalable à l'examen auquel le conseil
d'état ce livre se livra ultérieurement
nous n'avons rien à cacher nous jouerons
cartes sur table tout le monde connaîtra
la nature de nos travaux avant même que
le gouvernement en décide
merci monsieur pascal doit rester neutre
invite le ministre des